bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 30 avril
merci de nous rejoindre pour un nouveau
numéro de filecho votre magazineination
qui revient sur l'actualité économique
locale tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette
édition dans l'actualité de cette
semaine le budget de la communauté
d'agglomération a été voté ce lundi au
programme des économies lié à la baisse
des dotations aux communes nous y
reviendrons du nouveau dans l'affaire
Promopole une forme de conciliation
aurait été trouvé entre la pépinière et
la ville de trappe pour les bâtiments
Torz Meziers enfin dans l'entreprise de
la semaine des spécialistes dans la
prise de vue aérienne caméra hélicoptère
avec son matériel de pointe ACS France
couvre Roland Garros où travail avec Ray
Lescott nous vous la présenterons et
notre entretien cette semaine sera
consacré au réseau d'accompagne ement
pour les entrepreneurs quelles aides
quelle solutions apporent-t-il de la
création à la pérénisation de
l'entreprise pour répondre à ces
questions avec moi en plateau Michel
Zella bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de BG Eveline réseau national
d'appui aux entrepreneurs vous répondrez
à nos questions et nous reviendrons sur
ce sujet mais avant cela passons en
revue l'actualité économique de la
semaine et le budget de l'agglomération
a été adopté lundi dernier budget
contraint en raison de la baisse des
dotations budgétaires 5 millions d'euros
étaiit à trouver conséquen économie et
mutualisations sont à l'ordre du jour
Catherine
zulado un budget volontariste et
courageux c'est ainsi que laa présenté
Armel aubrier ce lundi soir en conseil
communautaire malgré 5 millions d'euros
d'économie à faire pour l'agglomération
pas question d'augmenter la pression
fiscale de réduire les investissements à
hauteur de 48 millions d'euros ou encore
de supprimer l'accompagnement aux
communes de 38 millions d'euros via le
pacte financier
par contre la majorité a souhaité se
recentrer sur ses compétences
prioritaires et revoir certains postes
comme les frais de personnel en baisse
de 350000 € les ados associations on a
aussi fait des efforts énormes dans nos
frais de fonctionnement notamment la
masse salariale on essaie d'être
vigilant là-dessus et chaque poste
vraiment est étudié avec beaucoup de
précaution on a aussi ben diminué aussi
certaines opérations sportive culturelle
il faut que tout le monde soit
aujourd'hui traité de la même façon le
suivi de la vie associative dépend déjà
d'une d'une ville d'une collectivité
d'une commune et là bien l'agloo pour
faire plaisir à tout le monde avait
abondé aussi sans critères bien bien
évident donc là nous aujourd'hui on veut
on veut revoir tout ça et on veut que
chacun s'assume l'accent est mis aussi
sur la mutualisation de certains
services en ligne de mire la Maison de
la poésie ou encore la Maison de
l'Environnement il faut faire autant
avec moi nous avons fait réaliser des
audits et ces audites aussi nous ont
prouvé que ce que nous pensions était la
bonne solution à appliquer dans les
prochaines années donc aujourd'hui c'est
pas de de de s'interroger si on continue
ou non faire de la poésie à
Saint-Quentin la poésie a toute sa place
sauf que une maison de la poésie ça fait
peut-être beaucoup donc aujourd'hui on
préfère mutualiser à travers le réseau
des médiiathèques que nous avons sur
notre territoire pareil la même chose
pour la Maison de l'Environnement il
faut revenir aujourd'hui à des choses
plus justes une baisse de 400000 € pour
le soutien aux équipements culturels
tous sont concernés de la ferme du
Mousseau d'lencour à la meuriss de
trappe financer des équipements
communaux sur le budget de l'aglot dans
le cadre de laapti culturelle ce n'est
pas du ressort de la communauté
d'agglomération donc là on revient sur
ces participations le budget de
l'agglomération a été voté à la majorité
l'opposition s'est longuement exprimé
contre la baisse des aides aux salalles
de spectacle les élus de la minorité ont
également regretté le mode de
fonctionnement et de ne pas avoir été
concerté dans les choix qui ont été pris
l'opposition a voté contre la section de
fonctionnement et s'est abstenu pour la
section
d'investissement et je vous disais en
titre il y a du nouveau dans le dossier
promopol vous le savez la pépinière
d'entreprise connaît actuellement des
difficultés financières mais un
protocole d'accord vient d'être trouvé
entre la Communauté d'Agglomération
actionnaire majoritaire de Promopole et
la ville de trappe pour les bâtiments
dit Torz meziier bâtiment qui avait fait
l'objet d'une convention en 2007 la
délégation de service public sera
résiliée à compté du 1er juillet
prochain la Ville de trappe reprend
l'ensemble des bien des sites des
mriziers et de Maurice Torz pour la
suite d'ici 3 semaines le 3 semaines
pardon le tribunal de commerce devrait
rendre son avis sur la situation
économique de la
pépinière
18,4 million d'euros c'est ce qui avait
dépensé les Français l'année dernière
pour l'achat de muget cette année les
petites clochettes blanches sont bien au
rendez-vous les professionnels de la
filière ne manque pas l'occasion de
sortir les brins et les pots il faut
faire vite car les ventes ne se font que
sur de jours exemple dans ce magasin de
montiny le Bretonneux Catherine zulato
et Mathilde
caberne Paul est un habitué fidèle
client de la boutique depuis plus de 20
ans avec son épouse le 1er mai tradition
du muget oblige il est venu faire le
plein cooup de la facture 54,50 € c'est
une fois par an
c'est c'est
normal vous faites un peu attention au
prix ou c'est la
composition la composition puis le prix
quand même parce que avec la crise ce
mercredi matin chez cette fleuriste cela
ne désemplie pas ici 80 % des étales
sont consacré à la fée Clochette entre
le muguet en poau à replanter dans son
jardin ou les brins coupés il y en a
pour tous les prix à partir d'1 € le
brin jusqu'à près de 50 € pour une
composition alors je
chez 10 dans ce carton les fameux brins
arrivés directement ce matin de ringis
son producteur est Nant le muguet en
peau est lui cultivé sous serre et
provient des ivelines l'enjeu est de
taille pour la professionnelle il faut
faire vite et bien les ventes vont
s'échelonner entre ce mercredi et
dimanche nous commandons notre muget à
peu près 3 semaines à mois avant le 1er
mai nous récupérons moi je suis allée ce
matin au W chercher mon muguet parce que
nous avons pas de chambre froide donc on
travaille qu'en muguet très frais et on
ne sait pas une semaine avant comment
sera le muguet en fonction du temps donc
cette année beaucoup de chance on a du
très beau muguet il fait pas beau mais
on a du beau muguet c'est un produit
pour nous qui est certainement le
produit le plus difficile à gérer au
niveau par rapport aux autres fêtes
parce que là on est vraiment tributaire
du temps ici la vente du muget permet de
réaliser 15 % du chiffre d'affaires de
l'année c'est toutefois moins que pour
la Saint-Valentin ou la fête des mèes au
cours du marché ce mercredi la botte de
50 brins de muguet s' acheté entre 10 et
20 € selon la qualité et le lieu de
production l'en passé en France en
raison d'une qualité moyenne 2,3
millions de pot ont été vendus alors que
les achats de brin étaient en recul de
19 %. et si vous voulez choisir un beau
brin de muguet voici le conseil de la
fleuriste il faut prendre un muguet qui
commence à s'ouvrir et le mettre bien à
l'eau et bien sûr bon au frais mais
cette année il a pas de
problème et voilà vous avez tous les
conseils donc N n'oubliez pas d'acheter
votre muguet demain un mot de transport
elles sont arrivées les premières
autolibes sont dès à présent disponibles
dans les iines la première station se
trouve au chînet cinq voitures sont
installées elles sont disponibles 24h/
24 la station va être officiellement
inaugurée le 13 juin l'abonnement annuel
coûte 120 €, la demi-heure revient à
5,50 € pour les utilisateurs et sans
engagement le tarif passe à 9 € le coût
d'installation de chacune des stations
est estimé à 50000 € l'investissement
devrait être amorti d'ici 15 ans 15 ans
pardon cinq autres stations de six
places devraient être installées dans la
ville je vous propose maintenant de
passer à notre entretien de la
semaine et nous sommes en plateau avec
Michel Zella qui je le rappelle est le
directeur de BG Ylin alors tout d'abord
un chiffre en février 2015 la création
d'entreprise dans les Ylin était en
augmentation de 3,6 % par rapport à
l'année dernière alors Michela vous
accompagnez des créateurs d'entreprise
avec BGE Ylin quelles sont un petit peu
les démarches que l'on doit faire pour
se faire aider alors euh déjà faut
vouloir se faire aider euh la plupart
des personnes qui veulent créer une
entreprise le font seul en France euh et
il y en a de leur de 10 à 20 % qui euh
euh cherch un accompagnement euh et euh
et c'est vrai que
euh l'intérêt de se faire accompagner
est assez euh euh évident lorsqu'on on
regarde les chiffres s'il y a un chiffre
à retenir dans ce domaineel c'est les
taux de pérennité des entreprises créées
euh les taux augmentent de 15 à 20 %
donc de de probabilité de de de
pérennité de survie de l'entreprise à
terme si on se fait accompagner par un
organisme est-ce que vous savez pourquoi
les gens peut-être hésitent ou les
entrepreneurs ne vont pas directement
vers un réseau d'accompagnement c'est un
manque de communication c'est oui en
effet c'est surtout parce qu'ils ne
savent pas ce qui existe il existe quand
même beaucoup de solutions pour se faire
aider euh alors pour pas pour tous les
publics en fait c'est vrai que euh les
publics qui peuvent d'abord obtenir une
aide euh c'est d'abord les publics les
plus éloignés de l'emploi c'est la
logique de de soutien des des des fonds
publics puisque ces interventions sont
gratuites pour ces personnes-là euh et
dans ce cas-là en effet c'est à
condition d'être en dans une optique de
créer une activité alors en l'occurrence
peut-être faute de trouver un emploi bon
c'est pas les seul public le principe de
de nare 200 voilà alors c'est tout à
fait le le principe du dispositif de
l'État le dispositif institutionnel
nacre qui s'adresse au demandeur
d'emploi euh mais mais c'est pas je
dirais la condition absolue pour se
faire aider notre organisme bchin
s'adresse également au salariés
après ça va dépendre du contexte donc
pour se faire aider il faut s'adresser à
l'organisme et on étudie le stat de la
personne sa situation et on voit les
possibilités de prise en charge quelles
sont les demandes récurrentes des
entrepreneurs quand ils viennent vous
voir sur quoi vraiment demandent-il
conseil alors nous on organise des
réunions d'information gratuites tous
les 15 jours donc dans ce cadre on
accueille un public qui est vraiment en
en première question sur leur projets de
création d'entreprise les premières
questions qui viennent c'est les
question d'aspect juridique sur les
aspects juridiques c'est souvent ce qui
est est dans les premières
interrogations alors le rôle des
consultants qui animent ces réunions
c'est d'abord de leur dire que ces
questions-l elles sont importantes mais
elles ne sont pas prioritaires on est
tout à fait en capacité de répondre on
va donner des premiers éléments sur les
aspects juridiques les les incidences
fiscales sociales et cetera de l'option
pour tel ou tel statut mais le plus
important c'est d'abord de réfléchir à
son projet euh au contexte dans lequel
on se lance donc l'adéquation entre ce
que l'on envisage de faire et nos
compétences par exemple et puis bien sûr
l'étude du marché l'étude financière du
projet et cetera et Christophe Eva vient
de nous rejoindre en plateau et nous
avons un petit retard mais tout est
pardonné il n'y a pas de problème alors
justement sur les réseaux d'entreprisees
vous vous êtes chef d'entreprise vous
êtes aussi à la tête de convergence
evveline qui est un club associatif pour
les entreprises tout à fait en tant que
chef d'entreprise est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner un petit votre témoignage n
dire qu'est-ce qui est difficile au
début quels sont les points important
sur lesquels il faut s'attacher bah
écoutez effectivement quand on quand on
démarre un projet en fait la difficulté
c'est de trouver effectivement des des
réseaux
d'accompagnement donc pour ma part quand
j'ai créé mon entreprise à Realty il y a
a presque 7 ans en fait le premier
réflexe était d'aller à la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de Versailles où
effectivement on m'a apporté un certain
nombre de de moyens de dispositifs et
notamment l'accès à des réseaux qui
effectivement m'ont permis de prendre un
certain nombre de de contacts et puis
dans un deuxième temps effectivement de
m'orienter plutôt sur un réseau local
qui me permettait effectivement d'avoir
accès à des acteurs locaux comme la
maison d'entreprise ou d'autres
dispositifs qui existent toujours
aujourd'hui sur le sur le bassin vous
Michel zella- ce que vous vous proposez
notamment aux entrepreneurs qui arrivent
de d'intégrer une couveuse c'est ça- que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus oui
tout à fait alors d'ailleurs nous sommes
partenaires de la maison d'entreprise
sur 50 ans n n on a une présence
départementale et sur ce territoire on a
des permanences hebdomadaires donc on
accueille les créateurs d'entreprise et
en effet on
propose un dispositif un petit peu
particulier dans le domaine de la
création d'entreprise c'est une couveuse
d'entreprise en fait c'est le principe
d'un incubateur de projet avec la
spécificité qu'il s'adresse à des
personnes qui sont au stade d'avoir
monté le projet on va dire théoriquement
donc d'avoir une vision des projection
financière de la viabilité du projet
mais il manque on va dire des éléments
pour passer à l'acte c'est-à-dire
franchir le pas immatriculer
l'entreprise dans ce cas euh à partir du
moment où on immatricule l'entreprise la
la seule chose et la première chose que
l'on sait c'est qu'on va avoir des
charges qu'on va avoir on déclenche un
processus l'incertitude elle est au
niveau bien sûr de la réalisation du
chiffre d'affaires et peut-être aussi de
ses capacités à faire face à ces
nouvelles fonctions de chef d'entreprise
donc nous en fait notre métier on peut
le résumé en en en terme de formation au
métier de chef d'entreprise et les
personnes à qui on propose notre
dispositif couveuse on va dire c
personnes qui ont pas suffisamment
d'éléments pour avoir une étude de
marché concluante donc une forte
incertitude sur leur capacité à réaliser
le chiffre d'affaires qui permettra
d'équilibrer leur projets financièrement
et aussi peut-être de voir si elles sont
en capacité de devenir chef d'entreprise
donc en quelques mots c'est un
dispositif qui propose un accompagnement
sur une durée de 4 à 12 mois euh et euh
qui propose à la fois un dispositif
complet de formation individuelle et
collective plus de 100 20h
d'accompagnement et une fonction portage
qui permet
de tester son projet sous un satut
statut particulier de tester le projet
c'est de réaliser un chiffre d'affaires
sans encore être immatriculé c'est un
statut particulier ce je je vois réagir
pardon c'est c'est le début qui est dur
ou c'est un peu l'après et bah écoutez
je pense que je pense qu'il y a deux
grandes phases dans dans la vie d'une
entreprise il y a la phase de création
hein donc le moment où effectivement on
lance euh je dirais le le le
référencement et une deuxième phase
importante c'est au-delà des 3 ans qui
sont effectivement la la phase de
croissance où effectivement on a des
recherches différentes du démarrage au
démarrage on on cherche surtout du
support parce que on sait très bien que
que l'entrepreneur est souvent très seul
d'ù d'où l'intérêt aussi de pouvoir euh
adhérer à une une association telle que
convergence Eveline puisque nous on a à
l'intérieur de de de convergence un
certain nombre de pôles qui sont pilotés
par par les adhérents avec un pôle
management un pôle lobbying un un pôle
technologique également euh de telle
manière à effectivement
soutenir l'entrepreneur sur un certain
nombre de points que ça soit l'aspect
juridique l'aspect comptabilité mais
même l'aspect euh aller chercher du
business parce que l'entrepreneur quand
même son son premier objectif c'est
c'est de trouver des clients hein c'est
c'est son sujet principal et on propose
donc à travers nos pôles également des
supports d'experts comptables
d'avocats qui sont des adhérents de
convergence civeline qui vont aider
justement et qui vont alors aider ou au
moins donner des conseils profiter du
réseau des adérents pour justement créer
cette
relation trouver les informations et
bien merci ce sera justement le mot de
la fin je rappelle juste que BG organise
un concours donc c'est concours talent
de la création entreprise vous pouvez
vous renseigner sur leur site internet
afin d'en savoir plus et peut-être voilà
je crois qu'il reste encore quelques
jours pour s'inscrire et y participer
merci Monsieur merci messieurs d'être
venu sur notre plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions tout de suite on
continueission avec le chiffre de la
semaine paô emploi enregistre une hausse
de 0,5 % du chômage au mois de mars dans
le département par rapport au mois de
février 87000 1880 chômeurs sont
recensés dans le département dans les
catégories A B et C en un an les Evin
enregistrent une hausse de 5,9 % des
chiffres dans la moyenne française en
Île-de-France l'augmentation mensuelle
est de 0,4 % entre février et mars et de
6 % sur les 12 derniers
mois et on passe tout de suite à la
partie magazine vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas cette société notre
société de la semaine pourtant vous avez
déjà dû certainement voir son travail
ACS France est installé à Buc cette
société possède des caméras ultra
perfectionnées elle filme en hélicoptère
sur des rails ou en voiture poursuite
pour le cinéma la télévision ou encore
de grands événements sportifs romain
rpin pour le
montage derrière ces grosse production à
l'américaine se cache une petite TPE
ivlinoise ACS France est située à Buc et
elle fait de plus en plus parler d'elle
créée en 1997 elle affiche une certaine
expérience dans les prises de vue
aériennes pour le cinéma la publicité ou
la télévision elle participe ainsi aux
événements phar de l'industrie du cinéma
français comme en février dernier lors
du micralon organisé par la féis à Paris
c'est un salon qui est le salon majeur
de l'année en France pour le cinéma on a
vraiment des techniciens du cinéma qui
viennent nous voir euh on participe au
sein de ce salon en tant qu'associé de
l'association et on présente des
nouveautés l'engagement de chaque
prestataire qui vient ici c'est
d'arriver avec des choses nouvelles Luc
Poulin dirige ACS France depuis 2003
pilote d'hélicoptère il intervient sur
le terrain ou plutôt dans le ciel pour
les prises de vue aériennes les
activités d'ACS nécessitent
l'acquisition de matériel ultra
performant comme la Shotover un support
de caméra à tête giratoire stabilisé
américain et fabriqué en
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est investissements
lourd c'est des machines qui démarent
entre 400 et 600000 dollars voilà donc
c'est difficile à rentabiliser parce
qu'il y a toujours toujours des nouveaux
modèles voilà on a fait des choix ces
dernières années de représenter une
marque qui est leader aujourd'hui sur le
marché on vient de finir un très gros
film de la Warner Bros avec le
réalisateur d'Harry Potter on a
travaillé toute la fin d'année sur ce
projet et puis on démarre un film
avecrit de l'escot toujours pareil avec
avec ce matériel là donc on évolue sur
plusieurs marchés avec le développement
de l'imag et les avancées technologiques
comme les drones la société ivelinoise
est sur un marché porteur ACS France
sollicité par le cinéma mais également
pour les événements sportifs comme
Roland Garos ou des matchs de rugby des
rencontres qui nécessitent des moyens de
tournage plus important en tout la
société comptabilise plus de 3000
clients quand on est dans la période du
sport B on fait tous les meetings
d'aththlétisme donc c'est c'est vraiment
la grosse
période de l'été et puis après bon on
rentre plutôt sur la saison des films
après il y a des publicités ENF voilà ça
il y a un roulement heureusement
10 salariés travaill à temps complet
dans la société elle peut facilement
tripler voir quadrupler ses effectifs de
manière ponctuelle jusqu'à 6 projets
peuvent être suivis en même temps ce qui
demande beaucoup d'organisation en amont
il y a toute la préparation du tournage
et et bah toute cette responsabilité
enfin on voit bien en plus nous on est
sur sur des produits quand même à risque
que ce soit le Ren arm qui a un bar à
bras gyostabilisé du cable cam où vous
avez bon des personnes qui sont en
dessous de l'hélicoptère c'est vrai que
ça demande quand même pas mal de
préparation pas mal de rigueur les
techniciens d'asss France sont envoyés
sur les différents lieux de tournage
afin d'assurer la logistique les prises
de vue et le bon fonctionnement du
matériel c'est le cas de Valentin il est
depuis 2 ans dans la société et est en
charge spécifiquement des têtes
gérostabilisées je suis allé voir hier
film justement où j'ai revu mon nom au
générique j'étais content je suis allé
voir good kill qui film Landre Nicole
pour lequel je suis parti au Maroc avec
un autre technicien avec qui on a fait
des images c'est le caméraman dans
l'hélicoptère et moi j'étais technicien
sur un autre système qui est plus ancien
et on l'a mis sur une grue de 70 m de
haut donc ça se passait dans le désert
près de warzazat au Maroc et on faisait
toutes les images du point de vue des
drones militaires euh des États-Unis des
collaborations prestigieuses qui ont
valu à ACS France d'être nommé au César
technique 2015 équivalent de la fameuse
statuette pour les entreprises
françaises de prestation technique avec
un bénéfice de 150000 € pour un chiffre
d'affaires de 2,7 million d'euros la
société est en très nette progression
elle espère encore prendre de la hauteur
d'ici les années à
venir et le métier de la semaine est peu
commun et on ferait rêver plus d'un nous
sommes allé au zoau de Toir à la
rencontre de Christophe grossior un des
curateurs du zoo il est en charge des
espèces de de la collection du zoau il
gère les départs les arrivées mais aussi
le bien-être des animaux regardez ce
reportage réalisé avec Mélanie poquet
romain rpini pour le
montage les girafes les lions ou les
éléphants voici quelques-unes des stars
du zoo de Toir derrière toute cette
ménagerie il y a Christophe grossor il
est l'un des curateurs du zoo c'est un
peu le manager des animaux dans nos
fonctions on a aussi le fait d'assurer
que les
animaux bah sont en bonne santé sont des
comp ement normaux naturels non'ont pas
de problème liés à l'aménagement de leur
enclos c'est nous qui avons un peu la
responsabilité de comment il vit au
volant de sa voiture zébré il vérifie
aussi souvent que possible les enclos et
recoins du parc pour le bien-être de ses
pensionnaires il y a pas de journée type
parce que voilà vous arrivez le matin
vous avez prévu de faire telle tâche et
puis il y a un soigneur qui a découvert
un truc une naissance un décès voilà ben
la journée part sur autre chose il y a
pas de formation évidemment pour ça
évidemment si on a fait une formation en
biologie c'est quand même mieux dans
d'autres parcs certains sont
vétérinaires voilà il y a un peu tous
les parcours tous les profils pour
arriver à cette fonction là arrivé à
toiri comme soigneur il a peu à peu
évolué vers le poste de curateur maladie
décès ou naissance il gère
spécifiquement et parfois au cas par cas
la population des animaux du parc c'est
vrai qu'on essaie de faire en sorte que
les naissances se passent bien pour les
petits et pour les mères et se passe au
bon moment alors pour ça certaines
antilopes c'est vrai qu'on peut arriver
à gérer le moment de la naissance et à
faire en sorte que le moment coïncide
avec la bonne saison où il y a beaucoup
de nourriture où les femelles sont en
forme ou voilà tout se passe bien la
météo est clémante et on sait que les
petits seront costauds aussi pour
l'hiver prochain si on a un hiver un peu
dur s'il fait froid les petits pourront
aller dehors ils auront déjà voilà
quelques mois et iront normalement mieux
que s'ils étaient nés en plein hiver
encadrer les naissances mais aussi la
traçabilité des animaux qui comme les
humains ont tous un passeport lorsqu'ils
voient le jour en captivité certains
animaux peuvent passer dans plusieurs
parcs au cours de leur vie et donc il
faut qu'on puisse savoir d'où il
viennent et où il est et effectivement
la le moyen donc nous par exemple pour
les ours c'est de leur mettre un petit
transpondur électronique une petite puce
électronique qui est enregistré dans une
base de données mondiale et qui est
accessible donc à tous les membres des
parcs zoologiques on le fait nous pour
toutes les espèces parce qu'on veut un
suivi de tous les animaux mais c'est
effectivement
important pour avoir un suivi génétique
pour les espèces les plus menacées c'est
important pour que la personne qui gère
le programme quand elle est gérée par un
programme puisse suivre tous les
individus toute leur vie et en fait
l'objectif le maintien d'une diversité
génétique dans l'espèce en captivité des
données essentielles pour les échanges
d'animaux entre zoos ils sont nombreux
et nécessaires pour la reproduction et
la préservation des espèces dernièrement
le zo a accueilli de rhinocéros
hollandais Vince et Bruno Christophe
était en charge de leur venu d'abord il
y a eu la négociation de de d'en obtenir
parce que il y a pas beaucoup de
rhinocéros activité il y a pas beaucoup
d'animaux disponibles notre travail nous
c'est d'organiser évidemment le
transport donc trouver un transporteur
qui puisse transporter ce genre
d'animaux sont arrivés ensemble dans
dans le même voyage et puis d'organiser
toutes les démarches administratives et
cetera
entre zo pas d'achat ni de vente
d'animaux la plupart des échanges se
font sous forme de don ou de prêt le
parc qui accueille l'animal prend en
charge le transport c'est une des
grandes responsabilités de Christophe
qui demande beaucoup de travail
administratif forcément il y a des
incontournables à faire voilà le bison
qui part donc faut préparer faire
attention ne pas en oublier on prépare
en ce moment d'autres transports donc on
est en faut obtenir les documents faut
discuter avec les transporteurs avec les
autres parcs donc il y a pas mal de
transports qui sont en préparation en
prévision et Christophe a fort à faire
demain un des bison mal part dans un
zoau portugais un départ bien vite
comblé par de nouvelles arrivées cell de
tous les futurs nouveau nés du mois de
mai
et c'est la fin de notre notre émission
merci de nous avoir suivi je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de fil bonne
soirée